der gewaltsame tod von george floyd in
den usa schockiert menschen weltweit ein
fall von hoher polizeigewalt tausende
demonstrieren seit dem gegen rassismus
es sind proteste mit teils gewaltsamen
ausschreitungen
auch die polizei geht mancher orts
brutal vor us-präsident trump erntet für
seinen umgang mit den landesweiten
protesten heftige kritik und sucht
zeitweise schutz im bunker des weißen
hauses ein ganzes land im
ausnahmezustand
ja das kann man so sagen ich würde sogar
mittlerweile so weit gehen und sagen
eine ganze welt im ausnahmezustand und
ist wie ging es dir was hast du gefühlt
es war davon erfuhr
es war einfach ein schreckliches bild
man konnte ich konnte kaum hingeschaut
weil ich meine ein mensch fleht um sein
leben und derjenige ist nicht in der
lage ihn loszulassen und klar hat ihn
festgehalten waren ja viele leute und
drum herum ich war sollte er hin und
wenn jemand schon steht und man man
drückt den hals zu er kann nicht mehr
atmen ist jetzt auch der hashtag erkannt
dann muss man doch es lassen also ich
habe das nicht verstanden dass man so
weit gehen kann und auch kein schlechtes
gefühl zu haben jemanden so umzubringen
die menschlichkeit ihn dann jedoch
eingeholt hatte ich diesen schrecklichen
moment
das hat mich wirklich schockiert mit
einer fast selbstverständlichkeit zu
sagen na gut so dann ist es eben so weil
man hat ja auch angst auch ver strafen
nicht was man jemanden antut
also es ist für mich unverständlich hat
das bei dir auch irgendwie so ein wunden
aufgerissen die du also
diskriminierungserfahrungen die man
selber gemacht hast weil zu dem video
gehört ja auch dass das ein schwarzer
ist er da liegt oder das ist rassismus
da gezeigt wurden ja nichts neues ist
den gibt es ja immer aber der wurde
dadurch sichtbar die rechtlich genau um
die und das ist ja eigentlich auch gut
dass wir in so einer globalen welt leben
dass nichts mehr so versteckt werden
kann
dass leute diese videos hochladen dass
wir das alle mitkriegen das ist nur sagt
in amerika oder heiße dass es vielleicht
genau daran liegt dass wir nämlich alle
das video gesehen haben dass es das der
grund ist warum dieser fall auch so
wahnsinnig groß behandelt wird zu recht
natürlich aber es ist ja nicht so dass
es das einzige mal waren wir dann etwas
passiert und liegt es vielleicht daran
oder was meint ihr woran könnte das
liegen
ich meine das ist kein einzelfall das
letzte mal war jemand glaubt der nur
joggen war ist ermordet worden oder
einer deren rudi getragen hat ist
ermordet worden
es ist zuviel genug ist genug man muss
aufstehen und ich kann auch verstehen
dass die leute auf die straße gehen ich
akzeptiere nicht die plündereien gottes
willen aber ich akzeptiere schon die
stimmen die erhoben werden dass die
leute sich wehren und dass wir darauf
aufmerksam machen müssen dass es so
nicht weitergeht aber ich bin ich kurz
immer darauf zurückkommen weil ich mich
natürlich schon zwischen sich auch
gefragt habe warum ist dieser fall warum
wird der so groß gemacht so schrecklich
wäre auch ist aber es gibt so viele
schrecken melde und da habe ich mir
gedacht kredit ist ja auch daran dass
visualisiert bekommen dass wir wirklich
die augen sehen wir sehen den menschen
wären was passiert wenn ihr das berührt
uns dann anders als wenn das leben oder
woran liga also wir gucken dabei zu wie
jemand um sein leben gefleht und stirbt
ja und wie sozusagen was and
menschlicheres gibt es nicht und es gibt
einen großen unterschied zwischen
denjenigen die das sehen und sich davon
nicht betroffen fühlen und die die davon
betroffen sind und das ist natürlich es
geht hier ganz konkret um den fall von
rassismus den es gibt seitdem ist die
menschheit gibt und dieser tiefe schmerz
diese offene wunde gerade auch bei der
schwarzen bevölkerung weltweit wird
natürlich daher dass diese wunde nie
geschlossen worden ist und dass das in
den usa passiert ist
dazu gehört natürlich auch dass die
ganze gründung der usa sozusagen auf der
enteignung von ureinwohnern basiert das
elf millionen schwarze menschen
versklavt worden sind deportiert worden
sind aus afrika und das ist zwar
mittlerweile hunderte jahre später
zumindest theoretisch so ist das
schwarze und weiße gleich behandelt
werden
aber das ist natürlich in der praxis
überhaupt nicht so ist sondern im
gegenteil und dass menschen umgebracht
werden dafür dass sie schwarz sind und
das ist einfach ganz wichtig das
anzuerkennen dass hier sozusagen eine
einteilung stattfindet in weiß und nicht
weil
und dass dieses völkische denken
letztlich dazu führt dass menschen
sterben müssen und dass deswegen
natürlich dann auch das mit viel wut und
schmerz verbunden ist möchte ich auch
noch mal mein mitgefühl einfach
aussprechen und ich kann das so gut
nachvollziehen dass sozusagen auch da
eine wut auf kommt die man letztlich
natürlich die man dann auch wieder
sortieren ordnen muss weil die
plündereien die die schaden ja der
bevölkerung am meisten aber auch großes
thema bei der polizei gewalt in der welt
wurde ja auch schwer diskutiert und da
hast du ja auch ein paar das in amerika
auch noch mal ein richtig großes problem
schon seit langem ist die polizisten
sind unterschiedlich ausgebildet je nach
bundesstaat es kann teilweise nur ein
paar wochen dauern und ich wurde auch
mal ich kann mir eine normale
polizeikontrolle in den usa es wird in
velen waren und hatte wahnsinniges
herzrasen es wurde nur unsere
nummernschild kontrolliert aber ich sage
auch zum anlass die hände oben der blüte
natürlich automatisch nach
fahrzeugpapieren irgendwo in diesem
wagen so lassen macht nichts lancieren
oben auf keinen fall dass man die hände
nicht sieht weil ich dieses gefühl
dieses ausgeliefertsein sofort ausfüllen
konnte und ich muss sagen ich glaube
auch wenn man niemals ist 11 nach
deutschland übertragen kann muss ich
schon sagen dass ich glaube dass das
problem der polizeigewalt bei uns ein
anderes ist unsere polizeibeamten sind
besser ausgebildet die die haben auch
andere methoden bei uns in deutschland
ist das problem dass sich der rassismus
quer durch zieht von rechts terrorismus
bisher einfach in der gesellschaft bis
hin zu diesem ja aber das darf ich doch
wohl sagen ohne rassistisch zu sein nein
es bewährte neben die menschen die auf
die es zielt bewerten ob das rassismus
ist und nicht diejenigen von denen es
gut und das haben wir offenbar nicht
gelernt bisher wirklich war
bevor wir jetzt mal nach deutschland das
thema ziehen die gebucht natürlich ist
in amerika extrem groß gerade das könnte
auch daran liegen dass jetzt einfach ein
kessel platz nase jetzt ist es halt
einfach genug die sind wahnsinnig
gebeutelt durch die korona geschichte et
cetera
denkt ihr das hängt zusammen spielt das
mit ineinander ich glaube dass das
bizarrerweise auch präsident trump am
ende in die hände spielen wird obwohl
man es jetzt gar nicht glauben kann man
denkt sich da ist ein us-präsident er
mit dem mit einem militäreinsatz gegen
die eigene bevölkerung wo er sich in
einem bunker verscharrt und das ist ja
das gegenteil von dem was die menschen
gerade und davon spreche ich also ich
spreche vor allem von denen die wir
demonstranten nennen nicht die die wir
darin daran ändern und da bin ich das
sollten wir auch ganz klar voneinander
abgrenzen weil das in die sache auch
verwischt um diese hier geht die
zahlweise wird ja davon so meine
befürchtung profitieren weil er sie als
er hervor tun kann als derjenige der
wieder ordnung ins land gehen wir waren
schon mal wählerstimmen gebracht
ja ich finde einfach gerade dass er so
viel unruhe reinbringt weil gerade als
präsident muss er zuversicht geben und
sagen wir kriegen das hin
wir werden es schaffen dass wir eine
gemeinschaft werden aber er trifft
wirklich öl ins feuer
und ich finde gerade dann dass die leute
jetzt sagen jetzt geht s recht wählen
nicht dass wir wählen gehen und das wie
eine neue regierung bekommen in amerika
dass die chance auch es zu wählen jetzt
weil dieses also ist ja die wahlen und
ich hoffe nicht dass du recht hast das
ist in die karten spielt weil ich finde
einfach er ist kein präsident der
zuversicht gibt oder ruheraum vertrauen
geht eigentlich das gegenteil macht das
gegenteil und all die bilder die
entstanden sind also die teilweise für
mich auch schon perversen bilder mit
dieser bibel in der hand
das ist für seine kernwählerschaft das
ist für die menschen die selber auch
sozusagen ressentiments haben vorurteile
haben diskriminierung haben die zu
rassismus führen und ich finde aber auch
nochmal ganz wichtig dass wir zum
grundproblem zurückkehren es ist finde
ich trotzdem noch einen unterschied ob
weiß er in diese polizeikontrolle kommen
oder eben schwarz so dass stellen und
das können wir jetzt auch nicht
miteinander vergleichen finde ich also
ich finde jetzt ist auch die zeit
betroffenen zuzuhören
das heißt nicht dass betroffene nicht
kompetent genug werden darüber zu
erzählen was eben ist und ich finde es
auch nicht richtig dass wir in
deutschland so zu sagen dass wir da
besser dran sind sondern auch hier gibt
es rassismus auch hier sterben menschen
ich möchte mal runterbrechen
konkretisieren jemand der folge steckt
jemand der ein rassist
er würde genau zwei menschen aus dieser
runde töten und das ist nicht charlotte
und das ist auch nicht patricia sondern
wissen wir beide
und was unterscheidet uns von einander
nichts außer dass wir anders aussehen
und der täter in banja anders aus ich
bin aber ich sage aber aber der täter in
hanau hat acht menschen umgebracht die
deutsche waren aber die eine sichtbare
migrationsgeschichte hatten und deswegen
sind sie gestorben
und deswegen werden auch schwarze in den
usa getötet und deswegen finde ich auch
dieses onlive matters ist eine
nebelkerze list eine relativierung und
es geht nicht um ich auch sondern wir
müssen jetzt denjenigen zu hören die von
dem rassismus betroffen sind wo das haus
in flammen steht
[Musik]